oh hi okay holy capot we have six icons
in the building today you might know
them as Swans in the current world but
just wait until you see who's
[Applause]
here I would be saying this even if
there was not a camera catching it
because we are so lucky to be in this
room right now I feel so lucky and to
anybody who's out there in The Ether
buckle up I can't even tell you how
excited I woke up with nerves and
anticipation I mean joining us is six
icons in an exclusive TV interview where
nowhere else will you actually see them
all together they have all joined forces
and fx's new show Feud capot versus the
swans please welcome Naomi Watts Diane
Lane Chloe 7y kalista Flockhart Demi
Moore and Molly
[Applause]
[Music]
ringal I'm so happy to
both
sides my
goding
out oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh my God I
did this is like the most nervous and
excited I've been on the show I'm not
kidding let's start with like what was
your first job um I think it was uh
Annie the first West Coast Production of
Annie in San Francisco in Los
Angeles did you play Annie no I I played
Kate which was the second to the
littlest orphan and then I played pepper
which was the tallest orphan and that
was the one that once you played that
you knew that you were going to get
booted out right after cuz you aged out
I was going to say you age out they
measured you the whole thing it's
strangest job isn't it kalista what was
your first job I think it was The
Guiding Light the soap opera the soap
opera okay diam what was your first job
um playing the daughter of media oh
wow in and we spoke we spoke Ides and I
was six I had no front teeth but if I
screwed up my lines nobody would know
which was a perk is this the one where
you were on stage stuck and you learned
a little bit of a lesson there about to
go to the bathroom before the show yes
yes I had to played dead in Jason's arms
and you know you relax your body and I
hadn't gone I I peed in his
arms he forgave me I was a child what
was your first job um it was on stage as
a um in a Mary Poppins Musical and I was
just about five or six years old and I
absolutely love it Chloe what was your
first job my very first job I think it
was like seven or eight for it was in a
Voltron commercial they were like a kind
of a transformer and they were lions
that transforms into robots and I was
the pink lion the girl was hence the
pink and I was the only girl on set and
I remember looking around being like
this kind of sucks this is only boys
like where are the other
girls holds true
today I've had that except for this
show
what was my first
chop um it was a dance routine dressed
as an ant to Sugar Sugar by The Archies
oh that was the the big the big moment I
love that okay now let's jump to like
the confidence either to walk away or
stay in Bear down and try to make it
look like you can do it all walk away or
lean in and try and juggle both you you
tried to juggle both I and I've I've
done both you've done both yeah you have
and I think different times call for
different things like you know when
Bruce and I decided to um separate and
divorce I knew that I needed to just be
with my kids I mean I was at the prime
of my career and I don't regret a moment
of it like it it there was just not a
question Chloe walk away or lean in and
try and juggle both there are plenty of
times when I'd like to walk away but
what would I do I I'm still here I'm not
going anywhere they have to Prim me out
with a Vaudeville hook and it might
happen
but I I I agree I would like to remain
you you know you also have had your kids
you've kept going you're very prolific
what's your thoughts on stepping away
versus when you lean in there are days
where I feel like I spread myself Way
Too Thin
um and what the hell am I doing but at
the same time um I would never walk away
I love being an actor I love that
feeling and um not walking away staying
here I love it no one wants you to
either so that's good Diane what is your
thoughts and feelings on this it's it's
like who would have the audacity to walk
away now I don't know if you did but I
did and I think some of us have walked
away from our careers at a certain
moment for mental health reasons before
there was any calls about mental health
it was really truly uh personal when we
did it it wasn't um modeling any
behavior for others I'm just putting
that out there yeah what do you think
about the lean in the walk away the how
you live your life in chapters if you
will um I felt very grateful that I had
a
choice um so I did make a choice to walk
away
and I don't regret it at all I was 99% a
stay-at-home
mom yes thank you I mean Molly you were
such an important icon to us girls
growing up as well and you went off and
moved to
France
and you made a very powerful Choice why
did you make that choice I didn't know
that I was making the choice when I made
it I went there and I felt like it was
the first time I could breathe in a
really long time nobody really knew who
I was so there was a level of anonymity
yes that i' never had yes yeah we'll be
right back